are you an illustrator
yes
you're very muddy
i was attacked by one and a half ton
bull oh
i am prepared to offer you a staff
position do you capture something of a
cat perhaps because you yourself are an
outcast
i do it to provide for the five hungry
and precocious sisters that i live at
home with
and we've had a governess i think you're
the first person to see the cats are
ridiculous
frightened and brave
like us
miss richardson has had an incredibly
positive effect on this family
were you painting something
here's something funny miss wayne not at
all
you're catman
a whole cat world
they will turn blue and communicate with
us in our own language did you say that
they would turn blue yes of course wow
what's going on in that funny little
head of yours
[Music]
electricity
okay louie i'm worried about you
i feel
electricity
[Music]
mr wayne
i have been called here because your
sister is concerned for your health
you have squandered it on wretched cats
and on a willful doomed tainted romance
how you've managed
to conjure images of such delight
at such a dark time
i don't know
just remember
[Music]
however things get
however much you feel like you're
struggling
the world is full of beauty
and it's up to you to capture it
[Music]
and to share it with as many people as
you can
[Music]
[Music]
you